yes it was on the phone whenever you
came in here's the attorney
no pumpkins that's awesome dude
yep she talked with daughter yes and
don't even
see it worked so she agreed that she
would meet up with me
so where when i mean we're gonna have to
make a trip to georgia that's right
she wanna start it used to be there
that's fine they'll
i mean look there's just a little bit of
psy bargain in that we did
what's that well
you can't show up and she sees you there
are you serious right now yes very
why though dude she does she think i'm
still getting high or what
i don't know does she know i'm bringing
you she knows we're together still right
yes how did the part about
not gino coming i mean what did she just
say because i mentioned that you were
doing good and i mentioned that we were
doing good together and that we were
still together
and then she like threw a curveball and
she was like no mama just you
well this kind of sucks ass dude right
and there's things i want to say to her
too you know
you know it really sucks that uh pumpkin
doesn't want to want to see me i mean
i'm
i understand i've you know i've not only
heard her i've heard a lot of people
and uh you know i respect it but it's
gonna suck
you know i'm gonna be a couple hundred
feet maybe from the girls and
i can't see them what
i'm taking a page out of your book baby
steps
it's a step in the right direction i
understand that
i mean it sucks it sucks for me but
you know we said we'll do whatever it
takes to repair it
if that's what it takes then
i guess i'll take my own advice and be
patient my time will come
you